vous prenez la mado coordinatrice de
famille l'espoir et deux enfants lohan
et joshua de l'association est née de
notre vécu
on nous sommes parents de luan et joshua
louane qui a 6 ans je suis à caa2 ans et
demi et de nos périodes
d'hospitalisation de nos moments
difficiles à l'hôpital on a décidé
d'aider d'autres parents qui sont dans
notre cas donc on a d'abord créé les
journées mamans sont des journées qu'on
offre à des mamans d'enfants porteurs de
handicap et on les bichonne de la tête
aux pieds pendant pendant une journée
pour qu'elle puisse prendre soin d'elle
ensuite on aller pique nique on a les
relèves azan donc la mission mayotte
mission evasan c'est qu'on prend soin
des petits qui sont à l'hôpital sans
leurs parents et qui viennent de mayotte
et depuis peu on a également eu du
relais avec médecins du monde sur
madagascar
moi même j'ai beaucoup de courage mais
j'arrive pas à comprendre nous épuise
cette force pour s'occuper de ses deux
petits bouts d'chou et en plus elle
trouve encore le courage dans les
situations de s'occuper des enfants
handicapés
on a un beau les chiens d'éveil qui
consiste à former un chien pour un
enfant qui a un handicap donc on le
donne gratuitement à la famille note
notre but vraiment au travail de
l'association c'est de pouvoir aider le
papa et la maman à souffler parce qu'on
est convaincu qu'un papa une maman unis
ça donne une famille unie et ça peut
vraiment aider l'enfant qui est porteur
de handicap